the actual function in the brain not so
sure yet there's a lot of different
theories about it but when you talk
about psychologically in your brain a
lot of people with insomnia though not
all report that they can't turn their
minds off so this is not every patient I
see but I'd say good seventy to eighty
percent of the patients say that when
they go to bed it's like the stereo is
playing at an 11 or 12 and they can't
turn it down at all so it makes it very
hard for their body to down-regulate to
be able to go to bed at night and in
those patients they tend to then be more
awake at nights little toss and turn
they'll think more they get frustrated
and when that starts to happen you
really don't sleep even more because
you're making your body 10 so your mind
is getting more and more active and you
said sleep debt so Angele there are
patients with insomnia who many patients
with insomnia actually over report the
lack of sleep that they're getting they
are still having insomnia but it's then
it seems worse to them than it actually
is so if they say they're sleep-deprived
they haven't slept at all in three days
if we actually take them into a lab most
of the time we actually do see that
they're sleeping on and off here and
there there might be little episodes of
micro sleeps or naps during the day but
they actually are getting a little bit
of sleep when we've looked at sleep
diaries of patients with insomnia and
they'll say that they don't sleep for
one or two days and the body actually
has a natural function after about the
third day to start catching up and you
get a little bit more sleep the third
night and that's usually where to tell
my patients when they start worrying
that they're not sleeping I say say the
mantra to yourself if I don't sleep
tonight I'll likely sleep tomorrow and
if not tomorrow then definitely the
third because our body has the way of
naturally catching up
so there's a few different ways that we
treat insomnia the first thing that we
always do is we look at the cause so
more times than not but not every time
it can be linked to a medical problem
such as menopause cancer chronic pain we
also it can be linked to anxiety and
depression those are the more common
causes there are some patients who just
have insomnia and they've had it since
they were a kid and we don't quite know
why so when we look at the cause we
definitely want to treat whatever else
is going on but insomnia often because
it becomes its own diagnosis and that
requires its own treatment so if someone
has chronic pain we want to manage the
pain but we still want to treat the
insomnia separately so what will tend to
do in our sleep lab is we do a thorough
evaluation and we usually have myself
who's a psychologist and a sleep
behavioral sleep medicine specialist I
treat the patients first so we try not
using medications initially and we use
something called cognitive behavior
therapy for insomnia this changes
behaviors that people do in bed none of
the tossing and turning I'll work on
patients thoughts about sleep so I must
get eight hours of sleep tonight or I
won't sleep tomorrow that sometimes will
or I won't function tomorrow that
sometimes makes it very difficult for
you to sleep at night we'll work on
relaxation strategies and also changing
the times you go to bed will actually
make them sleep a little bit less for a
few nights so their body's natural sleep
drive starts to kick in that is very
effective in about sixty to seventy
percent of patients who do it four to
eight sessions not even every week it
works for sixty or seventy percent of
patients just as the rates are just as
good as all the medications that are out
there and the weights are actually
better in the long term the other medic
of the other option we have for
medication treatments so you'll have the
treatments such as ambien lunesta Sonata
them all servers IAM and for some
patients will use benzodiazepines like
clonazepam things like that to help with
the anxiety those are another option
that will we'll use sometimes use them
in combination with behavioral sometimes
alone it really depends upon the patient